foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice
we help people
build wealth do relationships the right
way
and get in a career where they can
change their lives and do work that
matters it's a show about your life it's
called the Ramsay show Rachel Cruz
number one best-selling author many
times over Ramsay personality and my
daughter is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about your life
and your money the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five starting off this hour
is Rob in Pittsburgh hey Rob welcome to
the Ramsay show
hello Mr Ramsey it is a honor to speak
with you you too sir what's up
hey yeah um I was wondering how
um my wife and I can incorporate your
baby steps into our financial planning
um we kind of started off on our own and
then
um we found you so we are trying to just
uh get that all integrated and
Incorporated
that's awesome so where are you guys at
Rob financially what's your
where are you guys at just income and
debt and everything
so actually I am going through a job
change right now from the construction
field to uh becoming a financial advisor
oh nice
yeah so we are on one income right now
and that's um roughly 50 000 a year
okay
um we have between my wife and I we have
66 000 in our roths
um
we have 90 000 in traditional IRAs
non-retirement mutual funds we have
about forty four thousand
and cash we have about 40 000 as well
okay
um so we have no debt um other than our
house which we are 175. okay
dang you guys are doing great Rob well
done yeah thank you well done
um yeah well the you know the great
thing about your numbers and you guys
doing as well as you've done and being
wise with it is that you know with
within the baby steps you're jumping
ahead many steps uh all the way to yeah
to four five and six
um so continuing yeah to to put money in
your retirement and then looking to pay
the house off will be your next big gold
you guys have kids
yeah so we have two kids we have um two
5 29 started with for them
um each with roughly five thousand
dollars in it
um but my I had another just little
question about the the mutual funds that
we have that are in non-retirement we
are down roughly 11 right now and my
other question was should we wait for
the market to rebound before we pull
that
um and put it towards the house I I
understand
um that that's the goal um I just didn't
know what being down right now should we
wait for it to rebound or just kind of
put it towards the house now
well you so you've accurately figured
out that baby steps four five and six
you do simultaneously so you have your
emergency fund with the Forty thousand
in cash you're debt free except the
house and that and you're putting money
into your 401k putting money in the kids
529 and then any money we've got other
than that we're going to throw it at
baby step six which is pay off the house
and that brings us to the discussion of
them the mutual fund account with 44 000
at this down eleven percent so you're
exactly you're asking the question you
obviously understand this so you do know
where you are you know how do we
incorporate this you just live the you
find out where you are in this process
and four five and six is fifteen percent
of your income into retirement
addressing kids college and everything
above that that we can find reasonably
with intentionality we put on the house
so I'm gonna put the mutual fund on the
house now
it is down 11 will it rebound yes when I
don't know and you don't either
um by the end of 23 oh I'd bet big money
it you know rebounds by then but I don't
know I don't know
um here's the thing I figured out
if you follow this process that had so
many people have followed that is so
proven
four thousand dollars doesn't matter
okay
and that's how much this account is down
okay I understand yeah if you if you
make a mistake
by pulling the money now and it jumps up
11 in q1
you missed out on four thousand dollars
well four thousand dollars doesn't make
you rich
neither does neither does in either
direction right in other words if you if
I'm wrong if I'm if I'm wrong and you
pull it out now I'm not mad at four
thousand dollars no no but it's not it's
not the definition of Rich okay yes yes
it's not even the definition of a good
car okay
it's it's uh so it doesn't
mathematically the arithmetic of it it's
not an emotional thing or a statement
about wealth it's a it's a math thing
and so does the four thousand dollars
matter mathematically yeah in whether
you become rich or not no it doesn't so
you could do this either way and it's
not going to make you or break you
you follow me
I do so if you want to wait on the
market wait on the market but I wouldn't
wait too long
okay we do have two cars that are both
paid for worth about 60 000. um with
where we're at now would you suggest to
keep them or to get rid of them I
suspect your income is going to be over
60.
once you get moving here right
right yeah so I mean that's your your
income being 50 is a temporary thing
it's not it's not what your income is
going to be for the next five years if
you told me you're gonna make fifty
thousand for the next five years and you
had sixty thousand dollars worth of cars
yeah you got two dead gun much car but
if you're gonna make 120 000
average over the next four or five years
which you are in household income then
yeah you keep those cars so you know
they don't that's not thrown off so what
would I do if I woke up in your shoes
as weird as it sounds I would catch up
Mutual find out today and throw it at
the debt and because I'm just now I'm
going to get on target I'm just going to
be on target I'm going to put blinders
on I'm gonna submit myself to this
program I'm going to do this program
exactly and with intentionality and and
I'm not gonna sit and try to figure out
some way to shortcut and ride the market
or something or time the market I'm just
going to get out of debt well and what's
fun Rob is like just go on
ramsaysolutions.com to the mortgage
calculator and start watching even at
forty thousand dollars you know how how
much interest you save by paying off
your house early by applying this money
to it and you can watch versus three
months later though even on that it
doesn't matter mathematically it's more
of a thing of I'm gonna do this thing
pure
and so 11 but damned I'm doing it you
know yeah I mean that's
um that's how I would do it and in other
words here's another way looking at it
what if you had enough in there to pay
off your house
and but the Market's down 11 paid off
completely I paid off in about 30
seconds yep there'd be no arguing with
me about it yep so why not take the 40
and go in that direction principle yeah
same kind of mentality but well done Rob
yeah man like uh we are going along and
we found you and we decided to do your
plan what do I do I'm like well you've
got and then he knows the plan he knows
the plan better than better than a lot
of people yeah so better than people
I've been listening to you for 20 years
and I just leased a car you know he's
not that guy you know so
um uh it's about a whole life insurance
policy and took out a new credit card oh
my God uh
but but I believe everything you say
Dave if we have we get those calls I
love those all the time
I love those calls this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more births
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Cruz Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
the Ramsey gold planner with George
camel Dr John deloney and Rachel Cruz
helps you every step of the way in your
goal planning for 2023 they sell out
every year did they sell out today
today I don't I didn't get word of that
okay they're getting close getting close
yeah you left
just a few just a handful left yeah we
did two interviews I mean George did
today about this so we're right there
okay so you're getting out there get
some media hits yes yes but it's great
it's a great goal planner it's not like
as one lady said it's not a flimsy
little calendar I was like no no no no
it is a serious
serious planner I'm trying to get your
mother to convert to it
because she uses that flimsy little
calendar from Walgreens yes yes that's
uh Day At a Glance thing or month at a
glance monthly glance thing she's done
that for like 40 years I think I think
it's the same one what is it teach a old
funny nutrients an old me me new trick
show yeah but yeah well and and it's
different than just that right like if
you're just wanting just a simple
calendar you could print that off on
Google this is like has content has goal
setting has I mean it helps you through
many areas of your life not just very
spiritual part of your spiritual walk as
well everything Financial relational
that's right there's something in there
from Dr John deloney George Campbell
Rachel Cruz every day here it is all
throughout the thing it's a beautiful as
well it is a substantial uh gold planner
it's a year planner and it will guide
you and walks with you through the whole
year and they are very very popular and
they do sell out every year so if you're
looking for a great Christmas gift I
would suggest you go and get that like
uh today that would be my suggestion
ramseysolutions.com hit the uh hit the
store and get the uh get the old gold
planner going there all right Mary is
with us in Toronto Canada hi Mary
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks very much Dave thanks hi
Rachel hello Mary for taking my call
sure how can we help
um yeah I'm curious if you could just
wanted to get some advice or your advice
on some advice that we had received
about a mortgage
and we have a mortgage in first place on
our home and then a line of credit that
we don't have any we haven't taken any
money out but that is in second place as
a mortgage
and we're in a position where we can pay
off
that mortgage uh coming up soon but the
advice we were given was that we should
keep that so we have a mortgage of
fourth place line of credit second place
and that would prevent anyone from
fraudulently putting another mortgage on
our home by keeping that those two first
and second place mortgages where did
this advice come from a banker good bank
a banker told you you should stay in
debt what Mary and here's what's sad
this is a particularly ignorant Banker
not only because the advice is ludicrous
but it's asinine let me walk you through
it okay here's the thing let's say you
pay off your house is it different in
Canada let me say this is there any
difference
okay because she is in Canada so I just
want to throw that out there I I I
cannot imagine that Canadian law allows
fraud
okay it's not that it's something no no
no no no no no I'm not answering Rachel
I'm answering Rachel okay so if someone
fraudulently puts debt in your name of
any kind including own your house
it does not stand it gets removed and it
doesn't cost you a thing
you just have to go to the trouble of
removing it
it's not like and having a mortgage on
your house does not protect you
from that
they could still put perspective was his
point
do what
it makes it less attractive for somebody
to pick us up yeah well guess what
mortgage fraud is not rampant
in the U.S or in Canada
it is the most it is the most difficult
kind of fraud to actually accomplish for
a crook it's a lot easier to steal
someone's identity and open up a credit
card like light years easier to open up
a credit card in your name than to do
this and so here's what you ought to do
on the basis of this moron's logic you
should go deeply in debt and stay deeply
in debt all through your life because
then you're less attractive to Identity
thieves
that's how ridiculous this is you know
so no absolutely not and uh by the way
don't ask the fox about the hen house
I'm going to ask a banker if I should
stay in there that's like asking a dog
if it's hungry oh my God a hundred
percent of the time you should stay in
debt it's what I live for is to put
people in debt and keep them in debt
that's what Mr Banker says oh my gosh
yeah no darling no it's amazing how they
just play on the on the fear yeah do you
know what I mean like
like that's that's the interesting
that's the best you got
that's the best I mean it would have
been the argument that you keep your
money and put it in an investment that
makes more than your mortgage interest
rate yeah is at least logical and the
argument this one is not even this one's
like fantasy screwed up stuff I mean no
the the number of paid for homes that
get a mortgage placed on them
um fraudulently is approaching zero it
is a very very very small thing and if
you're concerned about that type of
thing you should have Identity Theft
Protection anyway all of you have in the
states we would send you to Xander
insurance I'm not sure they issue it in
Canada but um I can't keep up with what
Canada does but the only reason is I
didn't know if you're going to get into
like mortgage law like very specifics
that are different fraud is fraud and so
if someone if someone's son so folks if
someone signs your name
without a power of attorney to anything
and they put your name in debt you are
not liable for that there's zero times
that you're liable for that debt yeah
how okay so how would that happen can we
just like go down that rabbit hole for a
quick second take to happen it's a very
complicated thing I mean you have to you
have to sign as if you're her and then
you have to record it at the courthouse
on her house yeah I mean it's a
complicated fraud it's very difficult to
pull off because there's about three
layers of stuff you've got to do very
clearly it's not just like a credit card
no it's very easy to do a credit card
yeah yeah I mean if people do the credit
card fraud all the time but right the
the mortgage oh look point eight three
percent of all mortgage applicants are
fraud less than one percent yeah so
there you go Mary that's the
applications
and that's not even yeah that's fair
that's not even it was not even issued
then yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
sure it's going to be like 0.0008 yeah
that actually occurs right yep and so
it's just it's a non-statistical thing
but if you're worried about fraud and
you should be because there's Crooks
everywhere you should you should get
identity theft protection from Xander
Insurance everybody ought to have that
we buy it for all of our employees here
all of our team all their MC team
members there's a benefit of working
here it's one of our HR benefits and
because we believe in it that strongly
because there's just something all the
time if you haven't noticed or stinking
call me all the time on my debit card
and go oh somebody using yeah which I
still appreciate you in Mexico yeah I'm
down there again but I mean it's golly
it's not so sketchy
but Dave Dave's Cabo trucks
uh I do appreciate my bank though
they're very on top of it in that sense
like I do well because it costs them
money oh yeah not you yeah that's why
they're on top of it
yes they're service oriented and that's
not it's good that they have some
service but it's it's done you
complimented a bank well but it's it's
really not that altruistic I mean
because it's their money that's going to
be lost not yours yeah they're trying to
protect themselves by giving you service
that's the thing and you got to keep
this amount of banks but Mary that's a
that's a thing that comes up all the
time and um
uh no I mean the the fear of this is all
of the internet yeah I'm just really
shocked that a banker actually came up
with this as the reason to stay in debt
among all the other possible reasons
that a banker could have given this is
this guy's really lame so I mean he's
like bottom fishing here serious but
that's the way it is and I'm glad you
called Mary there's nothing you know
Rachel I've been doing this for 30
30 almost 31 years coming up on now here
and uh it turns out that 30 years from
now when I'm not here and you're still
doing this the questions will probably
be the same
[Laughter]
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com Ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host in
the lobby of Ramsey Solutions which by
the way
you should stop by and see us when
you're out running around and over the
hill and through the woods to
Grandmother's house we go for the
holidays and all that stuff come by and
see us we've got a free homemade
chocolate chip cookies free coffee free
all kinds of good stuff over here and a
big bookstore and you can watch the show
being done on the glass every day live
from one to four Central between now and
about the 22nd after the 20 seconds
you're gonna get best doves but you
aren't going to come around here anyway
after that so
um but yeah come around see us we've
always got uh 50 to cut 50 to 200 folks
standing around sitting around watching
the show happen every time where we do
it live and
um also it's where the debt free stage
is which is where Jerry and Brenna are
standing on the debt free stage hey guys
welcome thank you thank you where do you
live Dixon Illinois all right very cool
welcome to Nashville how much debt have
you paid off 87 000. all right how long
did that take 31 months cool tool and
your range of income 99 so we should be
about 135 this year cool what do you do
for a living I'm a manager for an Ace
Hardware rental department and I sell
Power Equipment like chainsaws and stuff
like that cool and I'm an office manager
at Pest Control consultanca pest company
in Dixon all right very good what kind
of debt was the 87 000. we had 30 000
Consumer Debt some credit cards alone to
our dad a couple cars and then the rest
was our house oh paid off your house
wow good for you you're young to pay off
your household are you I'm 37 33.
look at it weird people yeah I love it
way to go you two very cool what's this
house worth about 150. I love it good
for you very fun how long you two been
married nine and a half years okay cool
but two and a half years ago something
happened oh covid yeah yeah but other
than that uh what happened that uh woke
you guys up and got you on the path here
so it was actually uh December of 2019
it was right after Christmas I had a
dream car in mind and I was entertaining
the idea of I think it's time for Mom to
get a new car and being the wonderful
husband that he is I mean I think he
thought you know this is going to be her
life lesson I'm going to take her she
thinks she's going to drive it home but
we're not so we went anyways
um and we were actually in a we were in
a seven year term for our vehicle that
we had so we were going to go upside
down in it
um very casual want the car he goes and
figures the numbers comes back the
payment's going to be more than our
mortgage
um it was a big
pill to swallow and I'm like wow so we
just you know casually we're like okay
we're gonna think about it
um walk out of there we look at each
other and we're like this is crazy like
this is crazy something has to change
um and we had we had looked into doing
this before we got our DVDs from my dad
years before that but this was the
kicker
um and we got lucky because kovid
happened in 2020 so you couldn't go out
and do much anyway so that was extremely
helpful and that's where it kind of
helped build the momentum so wow
breakthrough Oh by heartbreak too right
yeah I'm gonna go get a new car yeah
there it is yeah I'm a car guy and I
knew doing so many loans back in the day
that I knew we couldn't afford it
anyways but she went so many dealerships
with me I'm like I'm gonna go with her
and just let her experience this yeah
let her see it yeah okay so we're both
of you on board like what did you guys
both leave and look at each other and
say something has to change did one of
you kind of feel it more urgent yeah you
know she always thought the idea of we
shouldn't do car loans but you know then
I brought her home it's my idea let's go
ahead and do this now you know thought I
was actually two days before or two days
after Christmas all the videos started
popping back up on YouTube I was working
out and I thought I took it home to her
let's do this you know now it's my idea
so it's a good idea you know yeah
Google heard you yeah it started like
feeding you all the all the content oh
that's so funny okay so for the two and
a half years you said obviously there
were parts that were kind of easy
because it's not like you're traveling
and going on vacation you did it right
in the heart of covet and pandemic and
quarantine and everything so what what
was hard though like because now we're
kind of back to yeah we're back to life
and moving to shaking but you guys still
were doing it yeah doing the plan for
the first seven and a half years of our
marriage we didn't have a joint bank
accounts so that was the hardest thing
for me oh yeah stuff in my childhood
just I was tight with my money so I
didn't want to let it go but I think it
was an episode I watched that first
couple days before we started or
somebody came on and said something
about combining your incomes is the only
way to make it work and yeah I went home
and said let's do it let's combine our
income Whoa man they just all in yeah
a lot of couples don't still it's like
it's the pushback we get you know we get
a lot of pushback on different things so
how how you get for me personally yes
people George causes some people not to
eat out and you because join accounts
how did it change your marriage for
something to hate on
way better talking about money yeah so
there's way more is more trust than
everything all involved into it so yeah
everything's laid out there's no secrets
which I would say for the most part
there wasn't at that point anyways but
then it's just all right there in front
of you you're like roommates like you
say you know we fooled our money in and
then we just blew everything else you
know we bought our own stuff that we
wanted to on the sides yep yep oh
congratulations you guys thank you well
done with two kids how was that because
there's a lot of families that listen to
the show and are on that this one likes
to go out to eat and have fun with the
kids and the fun he's the fun sponge so
um that gets to do all that so that's
hard because we have a friend that loves
to go and do things and you know when
the budget's gone it's gone and the kids
understand that now too they'll you know
if they want McDonald's how much do we
have left in the food budget can we go
oh no not this month we'll have to wait
till it Reese hats and so they totally
grasp it and understand how it works as
well you've had our daughter in
kindergarten her teacher came out and
said she keeps talking about this Dave
Ramsey who's Dave Ramsey yeah
in kindergarten you know and they know
when the budget's gone yeah when does
the budget restart so we can go to
McDonald's or whatever that's awesome
I'm big in the kindergarten Democrats
demograph's one of my big demographics
oh my gosh way to go you guys so cool
very very well done hey we got a copy of
The Total Money Makeover for you and the
live and give bundle and the uh baby
steps millionaires book because that's
the next chapter in your story for sure
you're on your way and a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
if you haven't been through it formally
yet go through it if you are give it all
away whatever you want to do it's the
live and give bundle all right bring the
kiddos up and tell us their names and
ages we have Arya she just turned eight
on Tuesday Hudson he is five very cool
all right so all the way from Illinois
have we been practicing our debt-free
screen we did watch some old debt free
screens on YouTube before we came down
okay so we kind of got the format okay
that's good A little bit of prep
very fun well the cool thing is is that
they're both old enough to remember that
time that their parents during the
pandemic changed their family tree so
you guys are heroes well done very very
well done I'm looking at uh little kids
whose mom and dads are heroes and change
their family tree it'll never be the
same because of what you all have done
so very very cool beautifully
beautifully played it's good stuff Jerry
and Brenna Arya and Hudson Dixon
Illinois
87 thousand dollars paid off in 31
months making 99 to 135 counted down
let's hear a debt-free scream ready one
two three we're debt free
[Applause]
that is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen oh man I love it very cool so
sweet very cool yeah really and they did
um man they paid off a lot of debt with
that income in two and a half years yes
yes that's like beans and rice rice and
beans they cut everything completely
focused completely intense which is how
you do it folks and if you don't know
the debt snowball is what these folks
are using it's where you list your debts
everything but your house smallest to
largest debt regardless of the interest
rate you pay minimum payments on
everything but your smallest debt and
you attack it with a Vengeance like your
freaking hair is on fire like your life
depends on it you sell so much stuff the
kids think they're next you're not going
to see the inside of a restaurant unless
you're working there you and your spouse
are locking arms and there is no
freaking vacations no way whiner get her
done you gotta lean in and go scorched
to Earth and knock it out no just like
that call the wambulance and get it done
this is how it's done right in two and a
half years two and a half years and a
half years man I'm telling you these
people were not moseying out of debt
they were running like their life depend
on it and now they're a hundred percent
free house and everything very
impressive and that ladies and gentlemen
is exactly how you do it this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today Steven's with us in California hi
Stephen how are you
good how you doing Dave better than I
deserve what's up
it's an honor to get to talk to you guys
today
um my wife and I recently inherited an
estate from a good friend of ours he was
an elderly man that we took care of for
about 13 years and he recently passed
um and we're just nervous to navigate
the probate process and the uh
the county office that looked over the
will it's a handwritten will said that
we shouldn't need an attorney but we
don't know if we should get one anyways
or or how to navigate it
okay
um what are the what what is the size of
the estate
how much money is it worth
well the his bank account was not uh I
was a beneficiary so they said that that
stays out of probate correct so they
they just wrote me a check for that uh
there is a mortgage on the home of about
150 000 still it's worth probably 350
and then he's got a car that's worth
somewhere around ten thousand and just
miscellaneous things other than that
okay
um
so you took the uh the handwritten will
to the county probate department or
probate office
uh the public affairs office is who
wanted it we haven't we haven't
submitted the probate paperwork yet
okay
and and he has no he has no next of kin
he was a single man
um we were the only ones that he really
led into his life
um you know we were next door neighbors
with them and and everything you know
there's a couple hundred thousand
dollars involved here in equity and
um yeah so what would I do if I woke up
in your shoes
um the fact that it's handwritten uh
doesn't invalidate it but it makes it uh
have more potential
bumps in the road
it's not it's not as it's not as
airtight uh necessarily it could be
legally I'm not saying it legally but it
just it it raises the
you know people people uh that you're
dealing with them so I I would talk to a
couple of probate attorneys in that
county and ask them what they would
charge you have you priced the service
of having someone run it through
uh the one attorney I talked to she said
she was going to get back to me and that
was over two weeks ago and she hasn't
called me back yet okay so that means
you're not using her
yeah yeah
um so I mean I wouldn't spend uh two
thousand or five thousand dollars to do
this but I would spend 500 bucks and let
someone else screw with it
um in a heart rate I would do that and
so I would look for some because if it's
if it is as the county Affairs officer
told you if it is a no-brainer for it to
just go straight through it's not a lot
of legal work for the attorney but to
have someone that knows everybody down
at the courthouse in that area that can
just walk down there and walk the thing
through and knows the judge and it's
kind of like going to traffic court at
that point it's just automatic right
versus you walking through there and
have never walked through this land mine
before and do not know where the bombs
are that you could step on that would be
me I don't know how to do that and so I
would personally Dave would hire
somebody to go do that for me so I
didn't just it's work but it's not worth
two or three thousand or five thousand
dollars for something that consists of
three whole assets a bank account that's
already handed off a car and a house
that's mortgaged
um so right no I wouldn't spend
thousands and thousands but I would
spend some money to have someone just uh
that knows the path through the woods so
to speak
sure and then do I keep his um do I keep
his bills current or do I let that go
into the probate process
what other bills are there
uh his his mortgage and that we just
paid his car registration uh we put
insurance on his car because it's parked
outside and we don't want it to
to get destroyed and or stolen and and
you lose the assets yeah I would do
those kinds of things but um and if you
don't pay the mortgage you know you're
gonna have to when you have to catch it
up uh later on so what are you gonna do
with the house
uh we might put a 15-year on it and and
get it paid off quick and rent it
um
what's the interest rate we were
right now
um on that one I think it's
four percent I wouldn't bother to
refinance it I would just pay on it
oh okay just pay extra on it you can pay
extra on a 30 and pay it off in six it
doesn't matter
so you don't have to restructure it it's
a lower interest rate than market so I
would just keep it
with being in his name though doesn't
matter
um and being a VA loan doesn't matter
with that oh okay doesn't matter he died
he died the mortgage stays in place as
long as you keep it current that's the
law
oh wow that's good to know yeah the um
the standard boilerplate VA deed of
trust does not allow them to call the
note in the event of death of the
veteran
it does it just as long as you keep it
current now if you don't keep it current
they foreclose on it obviously right but
so I would just keep it current and I
would go get an attorney run it through
and then let's get the thing paid off as
fast as you can you got a nice rental
how much more complicated would it be if
he had family that were going against
the Willing it's handwritten
oh well all of a sudden you've got
litigation costs now yeah because you've
got
um you know you've got a dispute that's
got to go before the judge and you
probably
I don't know it might be 15 20 000 bucks
now because you got to fight with
because of it's being specific
handwritten like no just because you got
to fight if anybody wants to fight it
okay just call me because I'm just
thinking like the problem with the
justice system is it has nothing to do
with Justice it has to do with you've
got to pay to fight even if the other
person has absolutely no case yeah yeah
well I'm thinking about like Mama Bear
legal forms how easy it is to get a will
right online and do you know do a
specific will and how much more
complicated it is when you don't have a
will or
you know a handwritten just like they're
in the middle right dude like it's the
how much it stands up in the legal
process it'll stand up just fine as long
as it meets the exact same guidelines
but it does put it more into question if
there's a dispute because you know what
what are they going to say they're going
to say this guy you know this guy
Stephen he you know my my dad kind of
had Alzheimer's and he went over there
and befriended him and talked him into
writing this thing out by hand and right
it just lends itself more to The
Narrative of some kind of something like
that if somebody wants to argue about it
yes yes um and you're more likely to
have done it wrong
because Wills are State specific and
um I've written handwritten will is
legal in every state but what is
required whether it's a notary whether
it's three Witnesses a witness those are
different in a lot of States yep and so
it's not a blanket federal law that
dictates what a will has to contain to
be valid it is different from state to
state
um and I'm sure California is weird
because California is weird on
everything when it comes to law right
all California laws are weird and the
other one that's really weird is
Louisiana because they're french-based
law rather than english-based law and so
you get all kinds of wacky stuff in
Louisiana too
um and you know and then you've got
stuff like Texas and Florida where they
just don't even have any laws no I'm
kidding but uh
but I was much more Wild West in those
areas so a lot of there's a lot of good
legislation I'm just joking around but
the thing is it is very different and
that's why you need the rest of you out
there listening need to go to mama bear
legal forms but let's just say again
because I don't want to get like 73
lawyers sending me hate mail a
holographic a handwritten will is 100
percent legal and airtight if executed
properly according to state laws
the only thing that could the only the
only negative about it is or the biggest
negative about it is one you could have
done it wrong because handwritten means
you did not get help usually and you
might not have the right number of uh
Witnesses or whatever two if someone
wants to argue about it it lends itself
more to the argument that's the story
about it that a week old person was
unduly influenced in some way right you
know by the crazy stepmother or the
whatever it is you know the arguments
that people always have so what we
always tell folks to do is get a
professionally done legal will Legal
will for your state for Mama
bearlegalforms.com and then if there are
relatives and this gentleman didn't have
relatives okay but for the rest of you
out there we're just going to use this
as a teaching session here
tell everyone what the will says go
ahead and have a reading of the will
while you're alive so if you're going to
piss someone off when you die go ahead
and do it while you're alive
you're doing cocaine you get nothing
you tell them okay your cocaine habit
gets you kicked out of the will just go
ahead and tell them now and that solves
it and then when the cocaine addict
shows up and once they're cut later
after you're gone it keeps it down the
lawsuits this is the Ramsay show
foreign
co-host on the Ramsay show if you want
to do your debt free stream live on the
show visit ramseysolutions.com debt free
screen we'd love for you to come to
Nashville and tell Dave your story
that's ramseysolutions.com debt free
screen
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice
we help people build wealth new work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personality is my co-host today number
one best-selling author and my daughter
thank you for joining us open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five hey guys I want to just stop a
second especially this time of the year
and say thank you
to all of you we regularly ask you to
consider subscribing to the show on
YouTube or as on your local podcast your
your version of where you listen to
podcasts and so forth or of course share
it with a friend you can do that with a
link or a text or whatever or if you're
listening on radio Just say Hey listen
to the radio station here's the the time
that the Ramsey show is on and you just
spread the word for us thank you so much
for that and
um we know that you do it a lot because
we just got this thing in from Spotify
this is your podcast was in the top one
percent
of all podcasts in the world shared
so you guys are sharing it so much
telling people about this on on Spotify
in particular that we're in the top one
percent of uh
in the top one percent most shared
globally I'll use their verbiage so I
get it in the right right place thank
you I know thank you for sharing it and
thank you for telling people about this
and we're glad that we're glad that
we're helpful yep and what's fun is on
like Instagram and stuff you get your
top spotifys putting out your top
podcast that you listen to are top songs
or top artists like you get your kind of
your yearly uh top top list and so
there's been so many sending you know
our shows and so yeah it's like the
Ramsey Show it's like Ramsey Show Dr
John deloney show smart money happy hour
virtual Cruise he was like I think I
have an addiction to Randy Ken Coleman
show all of them and so those are all
Ramsay Network Productions and uh
they're all of us jumping in and off of
each other's shows is what it amounts to
and uh and this one's kind of the
mothership that you're listening to here
but
um thank you guys thanks for listening
to Dr deloni for smart money happy hour
is a big hit
um it is it's a really really fun
um even for old people I like it
um ah until until
this week and I don't this I don't like
the blind love of his thing the reality
show stuff that was a painful
it was a painful episode but you and
George handled it the process well and
your addiction to those reality shows is
a little bit it's a little bit uh
disheartening but it gives me life it
gives me life
I love it Clarence is with us Clarence
is in Baton Rouge hey Clarence what's up
hey Dan Rachel it's really good to talk
to you and Rachel I have to say that
today this week's episode of smart money
happy hour actually enjoyed more than I
thought I would yes thank you Clarence
you're saving me wow your Clarence your
love is blind guy
I wasn't until I listened to it and
Rachel was so enthusiastic oh she is
enthusiastic you gotta binge it over
Christmas break you just have to be
careful what you're enthusiastic about
out there I'm just saying all right man
how can we help today
sure so um uh you know it's almost
Christmas time and uh we're on baby step
two but my parents said they wanted to
uh pay for the gas money for us to come
home for Christmas because obviously
that wasn't an option
um for us to come home while we're in
baby stuff too and you know there's no
strings attached they don't want us to
get any gifts or anything they just want
us to be home for the holidays with them
uh you know especially want to see their
grandkids and everything so
um I just wanted to hear your advice
about it because I just feel guilty
because I have been you know working the
baby steps getting stuff done but I just
feel like everything's you know my fault
because you know I'm the one that got us
into the debt to begin with and my
parents have helped us out with things
before with especially before we were
gazelle intense and now that we are it
just kind of feels weird you know
accepting their uh
charity when you know I just want to
kind of just do things and just kind of
Buckle in myself and just get through
the baby stuff
okay so I kind of want to figure out is
this a
um
a little bit of just like a pride thing
or is there a value system that you and
your wife have set this holiday season
and the only reason I asked is I was
talking to Dr John Loney about this and
about you know setting up boundaries and
like if things are just if they're crazy
like there's a level that you you know
may say no this year
um not necessarily because you can't
financially afford it but just even on
an emotional standpoint of like if
you're just like I just want our
families choosing something different so
is there any level of that or is it just
strictly you feel weird accepting money
from your parents for for gas money but
you guys want to go there
well I I think you uh mailed exactly
what my wife has been saying that she
doesn't want to see a prizing for me of
being just self-reliant
um uh it's more of just like you know
we've been you know working hard towards
it's not like it's gonna negatively
contribute to us it's not going to put
us any further in debt I just you know
my parents have done a lot to help us
over the years and sometimes it feels
weird for me being you know in my late
20s and you know I'm working on you know
various degrees so we're not making a
ton of money right now but
um you know eventually we'll you know
build up our income but it just just
feels like uh I I guess that's why I was
asking to see if it was a pride thing
for me as opposed to just a hey Mrs you
know it is a pride thing and it's not a
bad kind of pride
to just stand up and go you know I I
feel more like a little boy than a man
when I do this and it I don't like it
and that's okay to say out loud okay and
then the weird thing is once you say it
out loud it kind of loses its power
um and so like um you know we were
making uh pretty decent money we didn't
need the money and when Rachel was a
little girl her Grandpa uh Sharon's dad
owned a gas station
and it was kind of tradition when you
went in for Thanksgiving everybody
filled up at the gas station
and it wasn't you know he's like make
sure you get a tank of gas before you
leave more like you bet by Paul
especially the cost of gas right now you
know so uh but I I and but it didn't
have it wasn't because we couldn't
afford it that was different or it
wasn't because we were working a plan
that was different but it was still free
money from Grandpa you know kind of
thing uh so I kind of get what you're
saying I think it's a normal feeling to
do this but if I were in your shoes I I
would uh accept the gift and go home and
let them see their grandkids
okay well that's great that's exactly
why I called you guys I think that you
and uh Rachel uh perfect ones to answer
this so thank you so much it speaks
highly of your character that you're
struggling with this a little bit
if you let it completely dominate who
you are and keep everyone from having a
good Christmas then it's kind of gone
over the bubble does that make sense
yes it does yeah so I'm proud of you
yeah it's great yep accept it go home
for the holidays yeah that's great yeah
and um
it's uh uh you know interesting we talk
about giving a lot and we're doing the
giving show on the 14th and if you have
a great giving Story by the way email it
to us at ask
ramseysolutions.com ask
ramseysolutions.com put giving in the
subject line but
one of the most difficult things about
giving is learning to receive
um
very hard it's hard for me and I almost
can say more about I mean like there's a
level
with receiving
things
um especially things that are
out of proportion kind of things like
this over-the-top stuff yep that one I
really really really struggle with this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today best-selling author thank
you for joining us America open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five hey if you procrastinated blue
past Black Friday Cyber Monday we're
extending our Cyber Monday sale we're
here to help for this week only you can
get our best-selling books and tools as
low as five dollars you gotta hurry
these deals will end this week you can
get our quick reads like my latest the
momentum theorem Dr John deloney's
redefining anxiety all under 10 bucks
our number one bundle the starter
special has 77 percent off on it and
we've extended the Cyber Monday sale on
the ten dollar book sale which includes
all three of Rachel's books number one
bestsellers and uh baby steps
millionaires my latest number one
bestseller is ten dollars and Total
Money Makeover all there this is not a
place where you're going to find
inflation as a matter of fact we are
into deflation like recession
apparently I don't know what our problem
is Cyber Monday sale continues all week
long be sure and check it out
ramseysolutions.com our question of the
day comes from blinds.com it's the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and new promos all the time
check it all out they use the promo code
Ramsey when you do and today's question
comes from Rachel in Kentucky our 19
year old daughter just moved out after
paying rent to us for the last eight
months my husband wants to consider the
money as hers and give it back to her
but I disagree currently she has zero
plans to go to college and has moved out
because we made her it was time
I was considering investing some of it
or using the money to pay for college
for our other daughter who will be
graduating high school next year
what's your opinion mom is hard mom is
feisty towards her daughter oh I bet if
it was a son
she'd give him the money oh 100
oh water on my daughters I feel like
than Charles my little baby boy little
baby boy
um I don't know Rachel let me think
um
I mean I think it's fine not to give it
back to her it does feel funny using her
money to pay for the other sister's
College
um would you give it back to her even if
she has no plans like she doesn't know
what she's gonna be doing
okay there's
something wrong with this situation that
is not money
it was time for her to leave and I'm
going to take her money and give it to
her sister it kind of sounds like we're
a little pissed at daughter I don't know
there's a little friction here hello
between Mom it's time for her to get out
why hey I'm with you kick him out I
ain't got any problem with that part but
um get out there and do your thing but
you have to give her back
then too but don't not give it to her
because you're angry with her for her
behavior and then don't not give it to
her and double down on the punishment
and give it to her sister yeah that's
that's a little vindictive is the way it
feels a little bit here so uh by and
large I I think uh so that is kind of
sad though I'm thinking about my two
daughters and if I'm like I'm thinking
you're so mad at one of them you give it
to the other one
yeah it's like you little twerp I'm
gonna give it to your sister
um so yeah I I um
I I think your husband is probably
saying that uh giving your daughter back
this money is not a moral issue it's not
an ethical issue I don't think it is I
don't think you owe it to her
um I think her leaving with a little bit
of friction as she leaves sparks flying
uh as the uh as the old trunk was uh
drug out and thrown in the back of the
car or whatever we call it here
um
this would be just a little Grace um
I'm going to give it to her and just
call it Grace and just put not to try to
buy her affection or to cover over the
misbehavior or something like that I
don't know what went on
but you you know you said it was time
for her to go so there's something
something a little bit pushy there and
because we made her pleasure yeah
um
uh or maybe uh
she was doing nothing I mean she could
you know what I mean like yeah I don't
know so maybe you tie the giving money
back to her based on her behavior some
Behavior you want to encourage out there
in the wild
okay and so like um you know if you do
this or this we'll give you the money
we're going to give you this back or you
know like for instance and you know
honestly I kind of think Mom's pretty
upset whether there's a lot of emotion
in these words and I think probably mom
you step back and just ask your husband
to talk to her about it to the daughter
about it and uh because there seems to
be a little bit there and just say you
know we I think we might uh we might
want to help you in your new start
um and if you like went through about
you you're if you're 135 or something if
you match your emergency fund or will
um you know or if you're gonna pay if
you're gonna pay off some debt we'll
help you with that and we'll match that
up you know we're gonna use some of the
money you paid us in rent to help you
get started and to encourage some good
behaviors we want to go through
Financial Peace University you know we
would give you a thousand dollars of
this back as an incentive to do that and
something like that something that helps
the the daughter that left get our get a
sustainable situation out there but now
I would not give it to her if she's
misbehaving out in the wild yeah and
you're going to finance her misbehavior
by giving her her rent money back that's
not an act of love that's just enabling
so um yeah I so I I guess there's a lot
going on here that we don't know but
um
we are sure mom's hardcore no question
and I like her that's great because they
uh an eagle that doesn't leave the nest
is eventually known as a turkey open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five you know I found
that line was when you and I did that
book smart money smart kids
oh yeah your first number one we were
talking about kids leaving the nest in
that book and you know in researching
that book and trying to put verbiage to
some of the stuff that we did in our
family and that we've taught other
families to do on teaching their kids
how to handle money that's when that
line came up and that's how long I've
been doing that it just occurred to me
that's where that's coming from yeah all
right James is with us in San Bernardino
California what's up James
hey how's it going Dave uh Rachel Merry
Christmas God bless you guys everyone
around the solution how you guys doing
Merry Christmas same here how can we
help
um I want to know if I am taking a ride
on the rambulance or if I'm being
reasonable
um
my wife and I are
um about to finish baby step three so I
would put us in baby step 3B
but prior to that
I'd like to buy a car I want to save up
for it pay for it in cash because I have
one vehicle in my family and it's a
salvaged title Toyota Camry and I want
to know if prior to babyset 3B if saving
up for the car is reasonable sure
absolutely that's exactly where you do
it
perfect I was like James
now the the thing is obviously you know
what are the guidelines on cars you tell
me
James
um
I mean I'm thinking I'm thinking or used
Toyota something I and I correct me if
I'm wrong I think it's
oh my god I've been listening to you for
four years David
I put you on the spot to give you a text
no James you did not fail you didn't
know you needed to study no Dave just
tell me
so no more than half your annual income
in total cars the other car is the Camry
with a salvage title
yes sir so it's worth thousand miles in
it but it still runs yeah yeah but it's
not worth much okay and what's your
household income
uh household income is about 160.
excellent you do need some cars you need
two cars
yes sir yeah you're driving uh the
Camry's on its last leg and you got no
other cars right
no other cars and I'd like to buy a RAV4
something all-wheel drive I can't buy an
electric car like Rachel oh it's okay
James not everybody can be not everybody
can be Rachel in Georgia
um good no a RAV4 is great that's a
great car yes getting but yeah you're
talking about a reasonable car you guys
make great money so what are you gonna
spend on it
um
I I mean I'm in California everyone
wants uh EVS out here I still like me a
combustion engine I'm thinking 20 okay
25. all right and where are you going
what are you going to spend on the other
car because you gotta buy another one
too
I mean this one still works all right I
think you need to move up a little I'd
move up to about a ten thousand dollar
car probably
um it's well within your budget and you
need to it's time you've gotten the
emergency stuff behind you one two and
three is the Hardcore gazelle intensity
now you are moving from intensity to
intentionality you make 160 000 a year
you don't have to drive a piece of crap
if you save up and pay cash for it this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt free stage Jared is with us hi
Jared how are you I'm living the dream
how are y'all better than we deserve sir
welcome where do you live Atlanta oh
cool welcome to Nashville and how much
debt have you paid off Jared 37
271.94 cool and how long did this take
19 months good for you and your range of
income during that time uh started at 52
000 I made a job change gotta raise a
promotion uh took on some side Geeks and
now it's over 60. good for you what do
you do for a living I'm a healthcare uh
marketing specialist at Healthcare I.T
company great good for you cool what
kind of debt was the 37 000. uh so
student loans it was a credit card and
then a loan I took out to pay off
another credit card of course yeah of
course yeah real Financial Mastermind so
what what happened 19 months ago got you
started on this Ramsey Way so when I
grad graduated from college in 2016 my
one of my mentors my saxophone teacher
was telling me hey you really need to
pay off your debt start investing
Building Wealth and I was like great
I'll I'll do that I did not do that and
then I went to work with his wife and
she was doing the same thing so for four
years they were just pounding this into
me and I just I think I like said an
arbitrary goal like okay I'll try to be
debt free by the time I'm 30.
um January 2020 rolls around oh um I was
like okay I'll try to pay off the car
this year and I was like I wasn't even
Dave ish I was on like the Lacroix
version of Dave like just just no
substance at all the horrible tasting
water version of Dave yeah so uh
I I did pay it off that year and the
next month when I should have started
paying off another debt I was like okay
I've been good I can treat myself a
little bit this month and then I'll get
back on it next month and then so I paid
off six thousand dollars on the car but
I replaced it with six thousand dollars
of credit card debt of course and I
remember waking up at the end of the
year feeling just horrible I mean I was
like I have all that I should have all
this money but I don't and I got a
Christmas bonus for my job at the time
and I know I had to just put it all on
the debt and I was like this should be
my money like I hate waking up like
every every day feeling like this like I
have this weight on my chest and I just
snapped and I was like maybe it's time
to finally listen to to Chris and Kenyon
who were telling me all these years to
actually do this and start getting out
of debt and Building Wealth
that's amazing well and you lit I mean
and you did it in 19 months 37
000 making 52 to 60. so you did I mean
you sacrificed I did that's a lot yeah
it was a lot of cutting back on stuff
yeah went from eating out every couple
of every like several times a month
um to going okay I have a coupon for a
free Taco in the Taco Bell free Taco yes
that I split with with Julie my partner
that was our date night but I sold a lot
of stuff I picked up um I play saxophone
as well so I picked up some gigs uh I
dog sat for my sister I helped a public
speaker friends do his present do his
materials
um I was supposed to also chicken sit
for my dad when she was on vacation you
have to say that carefully yeah uh that
one uh didn't work out he the their
vacation got canceled but so I'm kind of
bummed that didn't happen that's funny
yeah it was a lot of cutting back and
big money and chicken sitting yeah
laughs
never heard of my life that's too much
that's so great way to go man how's it
feel to be free I remember the day I had
the LA the money to make the last
payment I was at my uh sister's house
and I was driving home and I just
laughed the entire way it felt so good I
woke up the next day and like it was
like seeing in color for the first time
it was just so it was so amazing that's
cool here we go back in debt now
what do you tell people the key to
getting out is
so I mean make the plan work the plan
it's not as there's no secrets to paying
off debt I mean so what really was it
for me was knowing why you want to do it
because sacrificing as much as I did
freaking sucked it was I mean there's it
was tough a lot of times and there were
moments where I wanted to backpedal but
I would stop and close my eyes and
visualize different points of what I
wanted my life to look like
being debt free I was gonna feel when
you got here no I picture it myself on
this stage several times to kind of help
get me through yeah pictured myself like
different stages in my life what that
looked like and that was enough to snap
me back into my
yeah was that your why looking at the
future self right yeah future carrot
thing
yep out there very well done all right
who were your biggest cheerleaders so um
Kenyan and Chris
um my mentors they actually got onto
your stuff about a decade ago
um and went through the baby steps and
they are they're they're living like no
one else right now and they came and
visited you um my mom who's here today
my parents my family
um all my friends I would post updates
on Instagram and people would message me
and say holy crap this is incredible I'm
so happy for you
um a lot of people um I also want to
give a special shout out to my um
Grandma Jan
she is someone I mean you talk about
people who live and give like no one
else like she is amazing she's always
been very uh open with her time and her
money and just her resources her network
and everything so yeah she's kind of a
great model for me very cool way to go
Jared we're proud of you man great job
great job very good job hey we've got
the live and give bundle for you The
Total Money Makeover book The Baby Steps
millionaires book both number one best
sellers and of course a Financial Peace
University one-year membership if you've
not been through it go through it or any
of those give them away read them
whatever you want to do they're for you
just to say thank you and to say we're
proud of you and thanks for hanging out
with us here today in Nashville well
done sir thank you good good work
congratulations thank you amazing Jared
from Atlanta 37 000 paid off in 19
months making 52 to 60. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one I'm dead
I didn't know you could buy one taco
that's awesome no it's a it's a
a coupon it's a coupon I know but I mean
no you're joking like you're like oh I'm
just like wow one taco no
self-discipline too yeah
very cool very good stuff what a great
great story what a great young man very
neat open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five thank you for
jumping in America we're glad you're
with us Sal is with us in New York City
hi Sal how are you
I'm Serenity how are you better than we
deserve what's up
so I moved to uh USA about five years
ago from Pakistan
um when I moved here I had nothing like
I literally moved here with like a
thousand dollars
um and now you know I I made my way up
um I now make about 150 000 a year wow
um but I took my uh wife's uh student
that a student-owned uh student debt
whatever you call that I just don't get
that
um it's for 23 000 and then I took some
advice from broke people and I bought a
car and my total debt right now is forty
five thousand
um I will be paying off that debt very
aggressively I think I should be done
with that by the end of 2023 but I feel
like I'm really late in the game to
building relics 39 years old oh you're
ancient all right how are you getting
around I mean 39. you got a wheelchair
yeah
I mean you sound like my dad right now
but uh
Sal you're good I understand I
understand because if you run the
numbers out you're like oh my gosh if I
started this at 20 how much further
ahead I would be if I started at 30 I'm
at 40 am I gonna no there's plenty of
time you got lots of time Sal and Sal
you're only going to be making more and
with no debt you're going to have more
income to throw at investing and to be
Building Wealth you're gonna be totally
fine if you got the curve from one
thousand dollars to one hundred and
fifty thousand in five years in America
I think you're gonna be okay
that is very good to hear from you yeah
you're amazing you're gonna you're gonna
get there my friend yeah we have a hard
break out sorry Sal yeah absolutely so
great job though we got commercials
coming in on us brother sorry about that
but we I know you can do it you're on
track you're doing everything right hold
on we're gonna send you a Total Money
Makeover book to give you the exact
steps
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today
news headline popping up here the
Supreme Court said it will hear
arguments in February in a case
challenging the Biden administration's
student loan debt relief program but the
Supreme Court kept in place a lower
appeals courts injunction that prevents
the program from taking effect for now
the plan is estimated costs 400 billion
President Joe Biden playing with cancer
but the administration agreed to extend
a pause so the Supreme Court has today
agreed to hear the lower courts are the
case in the lower court to prevent the
student loan forgiveness program from
going through the Biden Administration
and that's going to happen in February
so there's still two more months of
until it gets there yeah and nothing is
going to happen until then yeah and also
of course the Biden Administration you
guys are aware this is extended to what
May or June the um no interest so you
can go into your student loan paid off
really this is the time to get it paid
off yeah and uh this is going to be drug
out for years
because no matter what the Supreme Court
rules it's also going to end up in
Congress because if the Supreme Court
rules that uh that the Biden
Administration can go ahead the
Republican control Congress is going to
pass a bill to stop it
yeah and so you're you can just count on
this this thing going back and forth
this ping pong
um and again
we've said since the beginning of time
don't wait on someone else to fix your
life
you don't wait on the government don't
wait on the Biden Administration don't
wait on the courts don't wait on the
Republicans to fix your life you need to
go fix your life and that includes you
paying off your student loan debt which
is by the way your student loan debt not
mine
and I'm a taxpayer and if it is Forgiven
and paid by the taxpayers that means I
paid off your student loan debt I resent
that
well I do I shouldn't have to do that
and a guy who's a welder and a guy who's
a truck driver and this gentleman I just
met who's a police officer uh yeah they
shouldn't have to pay off your student
loan debt
um that's just there's it didn't occur
to anybody that that was wrong but
that's wrong
you know a guy who's working the guy up
here on the building working
construction right now hanging steel up
there up on top of the hill for a
master's degree for paying for a
master's degree with somebody in a
left-handed puppetry who's uh you know
yeah it's just wrong it's just wrong you
know all right Gregory is in Las Vegas
Nevada hi Gregory welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi Dave and Rachel how are you folks
better than we deserve how can we help
uh so I just want to say I had the
chance to speak with you guys here in
Las Vegas a few months ago and it's a
pleasure to speak to you folks again
well thank you how can we help so uh
here's my situation uh I am 29 years old
I'm single no kids I'm a motorcycle
police officer here in Las Vegas uh last
December I was in a pretty substantial
work-related motorcycle accident and I
am receiving a workers comp settlement
for it's going to be estimated for about
240 000 to 260 000 wow
um are you okay
um for the most part yes I have a bunch
of residual pains and aches I was in and
out of surgeries and physical therapy
for the past year or so fractures in my
back broken wrist and arm and uh tore up
my knee and pretty good so I'm happy to
be alive though yeah bad wreck
wow yeah I'm sorry man um yeah so I mean
it happened and I encourage everybody to
be safe out there amen but uh but uh now
I'm happy to be back at work now and uh
doing my old job so you're on the bike
again
uh yes sir uh that was my that was my
big goal to get back up on the
motorcycle and show myself I wasn't
afraid of it
so I mean get back to work is awesome
getting back on that bike scared the
crap out of me okay wow that's
impressive dude okay so how can we help
you today
so um I have been uh soliciting advice
from uh some good good uh friend and
financial Savvy family members about
what to do with my uh my settlement
money here and obviously my first
thought was to just go straight into
baby step seven pay off the mortgage and
everything I'm locked in at uh two and a
half percent uh on a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage I have about two hundred
thousand dollars left on it so it would
be enough to just uh just wipe off that
mortgage completely but family argues
that I could put it into even just a CD
at four and a half percent and uh get a
return on that and just that would pay
for a good chunk of the mortgage
throughout the year but obviously I want
to get some of it and um you know pay
off stuff and I that's my only debt left
so I was just wanting some Uncle Dave
advice
okay
um Gregory how long have you been
listening to the show
I think here uh about four or five years
and I and I know exactly what you say
what exactly what you're gonna say but
you know I I I feel so what am I doing
some firsthand what am I going to say
write a check today or when I get the
settlement ding ding
okay now can you articulate why your
relative is wrong
well I I look at it a few ways with them
they are I mean based on their four
years of listening to this show
can you say why we would say your
relative is wrong I guess it's a better
way of saying it
okay
well the data points
after we talked to ten thousand one
hundred sixty seven millionaires for the
larger study of millionaires ever done
not your relative we didn't talk to your
relative by the way
um we talked to millionaires
and um
precise the number of them that said I
used the money from my mortgage
instead of paying off my mortgage I used
that money to invest and that made me
wealthy the number of millionaires has
said that they used that technique was
precisely zero
not one right
not one said I became Rich because I
Arbitrage my freaking house
I borrowed on my home and invested at a
greater rate which is arbitrage okay
it's the definition of the term and not
one of the wealthy people say they do
that the only people that talk about
that are people that talk about Theory
and in the real world though the rest of
us out here live in a world of risk
you've just about got killed on a dead
gun motorcycle you know what risk looks
like okay right and and risk is we don't
know what's going to happen and
um we do know that we've also done
research that 100 of the foreclosures
occur on a home with a mortgage
so when you borrow money you increase
your risk and risk was not in
mathematically in the formula that your
relative used
right you are taking on more risk and so
if you were to adjust for risk and put
the money into a 10 investment you would
break even
oh by the way on the 10 investment you
also have to pay taxes so you adjust for
risk and taxes uh your 10 is going to
start looking a lot like four
and you're going to be back down to
mortgage rates again and so it just
doesn't work and and that is born out
then in the actual practical fact that
people who actually do build wealth not
those that discuss theories about
Building Wealth but the ones that
actually do it use their most powerful
wealth building tool
which is not borrowed money
it is their income
to become wealthy and when you don't
have a house payment sir you are in a
position to invest very aggressively to
be outrageously generous
um take a mortgage payment once you pay
off this house with this money with this
money this is just this is money that
let me say 29 years old yep and then run
out that mortgage payment for the next
20 years
in an investment in what you could make
investing that mortgage payment versus
putting this money quote unquote in a CD
yeah that one thing I'll make the one
thing I'm making a million that and
Gregory no one's accounting for and
people don't talk about this because
it's not going to be in the numbers but
there is something about when you don't
owe anyone anything John deloney talks
about this you have autonomy like you
when you don't owe anyone anything you
want the ability to do whatever you want
but whenever you hand a little bit of
your future over even a mortgage and a
mortgage is the one type of debt we
don't yell at people for but if you have
the money to pay it off and not to
have a bank have any say in your future
there is a level where your mind your
soul rests and you sleep at night when
you don't owe anyone anything and again
that's that's more of the emotional side
of this that is not put into percentages
and interest rates but it is it's very
real it's very very real
that's why Proverbs says the rituals
over the poor and the borrower is slave
to the lender you don't run into
generous slaves you don't run into
wealthy slaves
and this is the this is the principle
that we're operating on and it really
does work so I appreciate the good
intentions of your relative who is wrong
but they are ding ding wrong this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where that is done cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice I am Dave Ramsey your
host Rachel Cruz number one best-selling
author many times over Ramsay
personality my daughter is my co-host
today as we ask answer your questions
about your life and your money we help
people
build wealth do work that they love and
create amazing relationships Sam is with
us Sam is in Salt Lake City Hi Sam how
are you
better than deserve Dave how are you
just the same sir what's up
hey so I'm on baby step two I'm getting
out of debt and but that came a
promotion in my job
and with that promotion they gave me a
vehicle for personal conveyance and they
say that the vehicle will cost the
company about eleven thousand dollars a
year so I was wondering what your
thoughts are on if I give the vehicle
back and then just ask for that eleven
thousand dollars in the form of a race
okay well
uh I take it you have another car
yeah all right and what do you make
uh this year I'm on track to make about
80
000. cool what do you do
I'm a heavy equipment mechanic
okay so this is a truck
yeah it's well I have my work truck bed
I'm in right now
and then they're giving me this just to
get to the shop in the morning and then
to drive back home because this truck is
outrageous to be driving an hour and a
house and fuel every day
there's a big commute
yeah that you have okay yeah I drive
about an hour each way to get to work to
pick up your work truck
yeah
okay
um
surprised I didn't just let you take
your work truck is it super expensive to
operate
it's about three miles per gallon of
diesel being about six dollars a gallon
here it's you know okay so you make
eighty thousand you're on the road all
the time but not with this truck
if you have an hour commute how many
miles is it to your office from your
home
uh it's about 65 miles okay so let's
call it 150 miles a day
and
um
yes you're putting a lot of miles on
your car just getting to work you
realize you're you realize the value of
the vehicle that you're driving is being
destroyed by the miles you're putting on
it
well I mean it's it's paid off as 200
000 miles on it right now and I figure I
can at least get 350 out of that before
it's done
foreign
the math I'm trying to run in my head is
are you spending eleven thousand dollars
a year in Lost vehicle
value you're not with driving this old
beat up or not all beat up but this high
mileage old car you're not because that
car's not got a lot of value to start
with but if you're taking a a 11 000
value or twenty thousand dollar value
car you're cutting the value on it
substantially every year just with your
commute because of the miles you're
putting on it does that make sense
yeah and I mean I bought this car for
five thousand dollars I know I know but
I'm just saying if you were driving a 20
000 car it changes the equation that's
what that so I'm trying to run the math
in my head here
um
you know you're not really saving
anything on depreciation the gas is more
expensive in the truck are they
Furnishing you gas
dude you can't I mean with this you're
burning a bunch of gas
yeah
you need to add up what the gasp is
worth
yeah I did that actually the other day
Okay and the truck is about
260 dollars a week that they'd have to
pay for fuel and then my cost for fuel
is about a hundred and eleven dollars a
week
okay so half yeah all right and where
the car is not worth much right now I
just figured it was trying to appreciate
money as much yeah so it's the switch
and that
um if your car lays down
you're a mechanic you'll get it back up
hmm
so 100 bucks a week five thousand
dollars a year
for a raise of eleven thousand dollars a
year Well I wouldn't just turn it in
the only way I would turn it in is if
you got eleven thousand dollars
yeah and that's why I was gonna I wanted
to get your guys in stock because when
you divide that up hourly you're not
you're not picking up as much money
you're picking up three or four hundred
bucks a month by driving your car
versus driving their truck and them
Furnishing the gas
so you're not you're not picking up tons
of money here with eleven thousand
dollar raise and not having the truck
um
how many times how many times last year
did your car lay down on you
zero
I mean I'd keep up on preventive
maintenance you know I always have good
tires on it you don't have you know any
trouble with weather in Salt Lake then
no it's all highway miles so it's all
just you know they keep the freeway
clear and I know how to drive yeah
I mean I I get exactly where you are
um if we added in uh a different
situation with a more expensive vehicle
and some other things it really wouldn't
make sense it would make more sense to
keep the truck for 11 000. usually it's
more than that I'm not sure they're
going to give you eleven thousand
dollars to the truck because they
probably already owned the truck
no this is a brand new truck that
they're still making payments on that
they bought for you
yeah
yeah
and they have to sell it and give you
eleven thousand dollars
or you know pass it on to the next
person in line for a trout yeah okay how
big a company
uh we got this is so interesting
we got like 20 some odd Vehicles like
light duty pickups on the road and then
we have you know a bunch of heavy
equipment and a couple semis and dump
trucks and stuff like that okay all
right uh interesting well I I
don't know if they're going to do it
because I I think their mindset is they
want you in a reliable vehicle yeah and
they see this as having blessed you you
need to be very careful with your tone
and your language that you come off as
very grateful for the truck
I'm really grateful for it I think I can
come out a little bit better if you paid
me eleven thousand dollars a year
instead of instead and I would rather
have that would you consider that I'm
grateful though either way be careful
that's the way it needs to sound okay it
doesn't need to sound like hey man
rather than I have the truck
yeah that sounds like after they after I
just handed your trick keys to a new
truck that sounds kind of ungrateful
yeah so yeah um you know I think like
think like if you were on the other side
of this desk how you would feel right
yeah and that'll help you form your
sentences on bringing this up but yeah I
don't think it's the end of the world
either way neither one of these
decisions are going to make you rich or
poor
um but it's an interesting discussion to
talk through because company cars
um
when they take away the company car and
give you a car allowance you almost
always lose yeah in that scenario and um
most of you out there and because
they're usually running your butt over
the road in that company car in this
case
you know it's it's just your commute so
it's a lot of different variables in
this case this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number one best-selling author Ramsay
personality Rachel Cruz is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five if you've
gone through Financial Peace University
chances are it's because someone lit a
fire under you mom or dad your pastor
offered it at church a friend that
wouldn't shut up and made you go through
so you finally took the glass you
started working the baby steps and now
everything has changed you changed your
entire future you're able to build
wealth be generous got out of debt
maybe you need to be the fire that's lit
under somebody
you could give someone you care about
Financial Peace University and share the
same hope you've discovered
Christmas coming it's a great way to
give gift giving it's actually a gift
that is usable and that does matter and
when you give Financial Peace University
as a gift they get more than just a
course they're going to get the premium
version of every dollar so they can
start living on a budget and even join
the growing in on the group calls with
our team of financial coaches so this
Christmas give the people you care about
a gift that actually matters hope
freedom
Financial Peace University to give that
as a gift go to ramseysolutions.com give
FPU
ramseysolutions.com
give FPU
Miriam Is With Us in Tulsa Oklahoma hi
Miriam welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
I'm a huge fan I never miss a podcast
well thank you very much how can we help
okay so my husband just got a different
job it's actually with the same company
it's just a different job and a perk of
this job is
um a house so he's going to be taking
care of a ranch and there's a house on
the ranch that we're going to be moving
into
my question is
um when it comes to of course we'll be
able to live there until retirement time
but we'll never own this house so my
question is how do I pay for a house at
retirement so once we retire
um we'll either have money to buy or to
build
um
like that something like that
well if you don't have rent could you
just pay yourself rent
yeah so like a quarter of our take-home
pay would be about fifteen hundred
dollars so I'm planning on doing
something with that fifteen hundred
dollars I just don't know where to put
it to make the best investment for us
but with the intentions of it going to a
house so I want to be able to get to it
good I would just sit down with a smart
investor Pro and pick out some mutual
funds and have that fifteen hundred
dollars automatically drafted out of
your checking account going into an
investment every month
okay and then just I would just nickname
that mutual fund uh house fund
okay awesome that sounds great yeah um I
have another question if you have time
okay
okay so um obviously once we sell our
house move into this new house we're
going to be on baby steps four five and
six and
um my question is college so
um
my son is almost 12.
I don't see him going to college but
I want to be able to
um since we are able to financially help
him I want to do it if he chooses to go
I just don't feel like he will choose to
go so I guess my question is the way I
understand 529 is it has to be used for
college and I know you can use it for
nieces and nephews but he's he's the
youngest and so I guess my question
would be
is there somewhere that I can like put
money back for that would it be the same
kind of thing like a mutual fund yeah if
I didn't want to do it I took it in and
you're sticking an investment in your
name
and then if you choose to give some of
your money to your son at that point the
only difference is that investment's
taxable
and then a 529 attack and a 529 is
growing tax-free
right yeah but is that did I understand
right that if he chooses not to go to
college and I'm already interested in a
529 yeah it would be stuck there yeah
yeah I mean for Education you could use
it your husband could use it any of the
kids could use it you know extended
family can use it but nobody else and so
yeah it could get stuck there it's not
stuck I mean you don't lose the money
but you would you you know you would be
taxed and penalized both when you took
the money out and so if you want to just
go and pay the taxes now it's not that
big a difference but it does help uh if
you know you're going to college it's a
smart thing to do a 529 but if you're
pretty sure it's not then I would just
have money in your name it's just your
money and then you can decide what to do
with your money later uh again the same
you know nickname one house fund and the
other one college fund but they're just
nicknames they're both just mutual funds
in your name really when you get
technically to it you can do it you
could you can change the name to boat
fund if you want to I don't care right
Bahamas that sounds great Bahamas fun
that's one you know that's yeah um Cabo
you know I don't know or even in some
parents right they've done where they
put money aside like an enema
and then when the kid turns 18 21 it's
there or 21. that yeah if you want to
just put money in his name you can do
that
um and it will be taxed only at his rate
which is zero until it gets substantial
money in there
so but that's just money in his name
that's how we did our kids college
because 529s were not there was no such
thing when our kids when we were saving
for our kids college
and so Rachel Rachel and Denise and
Daniel all had money in their name in an
Atma and um you know that money when
they were 21 just transferred to them it
was just their money
okay
um and how much do you think that I
should be putting back for that
depends on what you want on what you
want to end up with I mean and he's 12
you've got six years so I mean um and I
would kind of I mean you know if you're
not going to do the college funds still
I would still save as if you were and
almost kind of just follow that plan and
say okay how much would it be if he was
going to go to a just a four-year state
school you know and just like kind of
let that be the range because if not and
he doesn't go that that money could
still be used for him to further any
type of training uh trade school he
could use that to to go forward in his
future even if it's not just a
Traditional School exactly and any lump
sum you got from the sale of your house
can also be added to your mutual fund
for your future house fund too by the
way just to add to this discussion open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Shelley is in Coeur
d'Alene Idaho hi Shelly how are you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve how can we help
I'm a retired police officer I was
retired due to Medical injuries that
occurred on duty so my retirement is tax
free
um I do have
um 457b as well so I currently work at a
second career selling real estate and
when I retire so now I have to pay taxes
but once I retire from this job and my
only income is my pension I will not
have to pay I will have no tax basis so
my question is should I be
um
okay putting 15 into some other kind of
account from my real estate money sure
or should I it would that just be like a
traditional rather than the Roth which
would No it should be wrong now and not
later yeah it needs to be a Roth
you got taxes even though I don't pay
taxes on when I take it out later right
you want tax-free later on the Roth it's
much better growth regardless of your
pension situation it doesn't affect the
Roth calculation how old are you
56. okay so you're probably let's say
you end up with a hundred thousand bucks
in your Roth and it grows to 200 you're
probably not going to touch it you're
probably going to live off the pension
it's just going to sit there and grow
tax-free which is awesomeness okay
okay so yeah I mean it's just a wealth
building tool it's not a mandatory so I
have money to eat at at retirement you
got money to eat at retirement you're
past that part but this is just a wealth
building tool at this point
all right so a traditional where you pay
taxes on it at which law would not would
not be more beneficial yeah because 10
to 15 years from now when you pull the
money out
ninety percent of the money that will be
in that account will be growth
it will not be what you have put in and
for all of that growth to be taxed then
so that you get a little bit of a tax
break now is a bad trade
okay well good I hadn't done that yet
because I couldn't decide and I kept
waiting for someone else to call and ask
the question and nobody did and you're
the one
oh Magic you're the one that got through
that's important stuff right so that
this idea that that grows tax-free
yeah well if and that is
not a pre-tax like oh that's kind of
nice not to pay taxes on that when you
take it out that's when you're a hit so
take the pain now pay taxes on it before
you put it in and then that way gross
tax-free you you you avoid taxes on a
dollar now and pay taxes on nine dollars
later yep yep or you avoid taxes on nine
dollars later and pay taxes on a dollar
now that's the trade-off this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Cruz Ramsay personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
we are so glad you are here in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage Thomas and Emily are with us
welcome guys hey Dave hey thank you good
to have you where do you all live
Jacksonville Florida very cool well
welcome all the way to Nashville to do a
debt free scream how much have you paid
off
so we ended up paying uh 220
525 whoa love it and how long did this
take uh that actually ended up taking
two years five months in one week all
right and your range of income during
that two years five months in one week
um that went from uh 125
000 uh going up to two hundred and
twenty thousand and just about at this
point we're about two hundred thousand
wow what do you guys do for a living
um I am actually a real estate agent
and I do
um at least mobile offices so anytime
you see a construction site kind of
start up oh yeah that's uh something I
end up doing cool awesome very good good
for you guys well both both good
businesses for sure excellent well done
what kind of debt was your 221 000.
well it's our mortgage yeah
yeah look at you too what's the house
worth
um probably about 400. I love it how
much you guys got in retirement
uh I don't know like 200. yeah that's
good way to go so you're most of the way
to being millionaires already I hope so
that's pretty cool how old are y'all
um I am 30. and I'm 36. I love it wow
not even 40 years old in a paid for
house worth 400 Grand how in the world
does that feel oh my gosh we
will that we own
we own Tire house the bedroom the
kitchen we just counted down the rooms
like okay now we own this room now we
own this room so the biggest excitement
was uh was getting the lawn
[Laughter]
so I got to ask you guys because you
paid off your house we've had a few
calls this show people that are like
okay we have the money to pay off our
house but I feel like I should invest it
and make more money and stretch out the
more you know they they're rationalizing
it with math just tell America if you
could go back would you keep the cash
and just put it in a good investment or
would you still pay off the house how
tell me about the feelings that you have
around this pay it off okay with that a
shadow of a doubt you pay off the house
knowing that there's there's nobody that
that you owe a dollar to is a big win
there's no feeling like I don't care if
we had a hundred thousand dollars more
in retirement it feels way better to own
the house oh so good yeah I love it just
the weight is off yeah completely free
yes completely free congratulations you
guys thank you thank you huge so well
done so very well done congratulations
so two years and how long you been
married uh four and a half years yeah
okay so uh 18 months 24 months into your
marriage something woke you up what was
the wake-up call my wife
yeah definitely yeah it was about uh
actually about this time in 2018 we
visited you at your old place and we
said we're gonna be back we'll be back
when the house is paid off and we closed
on the house in February of 2020 and
we're right in time for a quarantine oh
yeah literally the week before
everything shut down we signed the
papers oh my gosh and I said well we
can't be Liars to Dave so we just
started paying it off as fast as we
possibly could we know that most people
pay it off we got a 15-year mortgage and
you always say pay it off in seven we're
like we can beat that and so we're like
okay let's do three and a half years I'm
like we can beat that and then with
three years and ended up doing in just
under two and a half years yeah and then
you look out there and all that's left
is the lawn yeah absolutely
buy that I'll buy a Park Place
exactly okay so was it hard what was the
two and a half years like for you guys
it was kind of tough it was a lot of you
know well we can't do this we can't do
that it was a lot of
limiting ourselves but we just kept our
eye on the prize and we knew as soon as
we made that last mortgage payment we
can do whatever we wanted and he can
have as many coffees as he wanted giving
up coffees was hard
but it's it's totally worth it yeah
great job so what do you tell people the
key is
to getting out of debt yeah so I would
say the the biggest thing is to set a
plan a goal
um and do everything to achieve that I
mean because at the end of the day if
you start veering off from that goal it
it really does extend the time and what
we ended up realizing was
as we continue to push towards that it
went from as Emily said 15 to five years
to even less than that for three years
no two and a half yeah exactly just
start if you just have to start you
can't put it off you just say this is
what we're doing this is our plan we're
starting and nothing's going to get in
our way you know I I remember the
Sensation that it's weird that
the closer you get the more you realize
this is really going to happen and the
more intense you get the deeper you
sacrifice it's like you get the you get
weirder you know with your sacrifices as
you get closer because you're like I
want to get this done yeah it's like
gamified you know yes whenever we were
going to make the last payment I called
time at work I'm like can I just pay it
off like can I just make the paint last
payment and I'm like I just I can't wait
until you get home even I just I just
want to do it and so I just I called the
bank I'm like whatever it is pay it off
do it now and we paid it off and I
called him up I said we we own it that's
ours just like that just like that yep
so what's the first big thing you're
going to do now that you're rich
um we actually have kind of a
celebratory vacation plan for a
five-year anniversary so we're gonna do
that what is that where are you going
we're going to go to Cancun
they've loves Mexico yeah we love it so
we'll be there next summer and then
we're gonna buy some investment
properties hopefully and just make sure
we're set up for life and be able to
live and give even after we're not here
anymore we want to make sure that our
Legacy lives on and we're able to give
to other people wow you guys are amazing
I'm so proud of you
okay now that you got weirder and
weirder as we said as you get towards
the goal uh people make fun of you
anybody look at you give you the side
eye yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely there have been some that
question you know hey why why do you
feel the need to do that and I mean
especially as as you kind of referenced
how young we are it really was that ask
of saying you know hey you're going to
understand when we have the ability to
retire at an early age so that's that's
kind of the next goal at least yeah
totally yes yes well that's the great
thing is it just gives you options when
you have that freedom you have the
ability to save and invest and do things
faster earlier all of it because you
have your income you have your income
you have to do whatever you want yeah
that's awesome you guys very cool well
done well done well done well done who
are your biggest cheerleaders
um probably I have to give a huge shout
out to my sister Lindsay and her husband
Wesley they are huge fans of yours they
you know she got me started on it she
they were even going to go on her cruise
for their honeymoon they're Obsessed
the crews the pandemic cruise that
cruise was cursed but she got me started
on it and she was our cheerleader the
whole time I mean I would call her all
the time like we made another payment
we're this this much closer and she was
she was my first call whenever well
after I told him yeah after that then I
called my sister I was like we did it
we're done oh and so she her and her
husband have just been amazing that's
wonderful that's a gift too to have
family celebrate with you yeah you gotta
have people on your team that are going
yeah especially family sister like that
that's great very very cool all right
we've got the live and give bundle for
you that's The Total Money Makeover book
and the baby steps millionaires book
because that's the next chapter in your
story you're just a minute and a half
away from that so well done and of
course the Financial Peace University
membership and you you keep some of that
you give some of that whatever you want
to do with it and it's our gift to you
and saying thank you for being here well
done we're very proud of you Thomas and
Emily Jacksonville Florida 221 000 paid
off in two years five months in one week
making 125 to 120. count it down down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one we're dead free
so it's done
man 30 years old 36 years old eight four
four hundred thousand dollar house in
Jacksonville Florida amazing Mike
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
blessed is the one who perseveres under
trial
because having stood the test that
person will receive the crown of life
that the Lord has promised to those who
love him
Celine Dion said life imposes things on
you that you can't control but you still
have the choice of how you're going to
live through this
thanks for a Celine Dion quote wow look
at the look at the drama in that quote
wow
it's a great quote open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Daniel is with us in San Jose California
hi Daniel what's up
hey Dave how's your day going better
than we deserve sir how can we help
yeah so my wife and I got and I got
married earlier this year
congratulations
thank you I work at a church and she has
her own hair salon company and we live
in California and it is crazy here
financially
um we live in a two-bedroom apartment
cost us two thousand dollars a month
and my question is as a two-parter first
is we'd love to start a family but we
don't know when the right time is for
that financially to grow a family and
two we're actually looking to move to
Tennessee
because of that so first question when's
the right time for us to start a family
in two
um should we move to Tennessee if it's
or move to another state if we can't
handle it financially
well I'll say number two there's a lot
of California people here in Nashville
these days that were that we're meeting
and that are my neighbors we have entire
California refugee camps in Tennessee
so no people do move for the you know
what exactly what you're talking about
though for the financial reasons to have
a better quality of life because you
just mathematically get more other
places than you can where real estate
and everything's more expensive so
naturally you know you're gonna well
it's gonna be it's not just California
dude you're in freaking San Jose my God
I mean that's like some of the most
expensive real estate on the planet
you picked out the most expensive place
to live other than maybe Manhattan and
Cisco well this is San Jose I mean it's
yeah so how close is Silicon Valley so
there you go oh okay yeah all right so
wow part of San Francisco
um but number one
yeah I mean honestly we don't tell
people that you have to be debt free or
fill in the blank to get married to have
kids I mean you still are going to live
your life uh obviously things are a
little bit you breathe easier if you
have money saved I mean these simple
things but we don't have a hard and fast
rule of are you financially ready to
have a kid or not I mean if that's what
you guys want to do and start a family
then yeah I would I would start one but
um but just knowing that
um you know the more financially secure
you guys are meaning
you don't have debts uh you have money
saved in the bank all of that it's just
gonna make that transition less
stressful if money isn't a huge play in
it yeah there's only one choice that
you've got that's a better that's better
than the choice you made to marry her
and that's babies babies are awesome
amen get babies they're awesome okay
it's that simple all right and now the
question is then you know how do you do
that in a way that doesn't just
completely freak you guys out well
you've got to do a little bit of
thinking about the money yeah but
there's not a thing that says you know
you have to have this and this and this
before you can afford to have children
that's crap then start with they're not
that expensive they do cost I mean but
it's it's not people act like it's two
hundred thousand dollars or something
it's you know it's some diapers and some
formula and you have to pay the
pediatrician's Porsche payment that's it
I mean but then when you did you say the
pediatrician's porschement but but if
you know Daniel if your wife works
though you know you think about child
care I mean there's some I mean you got
to think through your life so that
naturally is going to be more expensive
but if you're going to move to another
state
and you're going to have a kid
um you know in the next 12 months then
you need to decide which one to do first
I wouldn't try to do both at the same
time they're both going to cost you you
know what two to five thousand dollars
to make a move two to five thousand
dollars to depending on I mean if you do
a cheap move and you throw some stuff in
a U-Haul if there's still any U-Hauls
left in California but if there's any
left you could get on that and take it
out of there and or get you a pods right
and um pods people are our pods our
sponsor will help you and you know get
moved anyway and but it's not super
duper killer expensive and neither is a
child if you've got health insurance
and so um you know but I wouldn't want
to do both in the same
number one you don't want to move with a
pregnant lady that's a bad idea okay so
let's uh you know let's think about that
and then on number two let's think well
it's not it's not fair to her I mean you
got enough to do you know so we moved
three weeks after I had a baby and I was
able to sit on the couch hold a baby and
just tell everyone what to do so that
was actually tell everyone where to go
that's exactly what happened yeah
so yeah just had a baby three weeks ago
no those are just big Life Changes
Daniel they're just big life changes
that naturally are going to cause stress
it's not I mean you're just naturally
going to be a little bit more on edge
when given a choice I wouldn't do them
all at once yeah
yeah
so I mean I I would do one and then the
other how long have you guys been
married Daniel you just got married the
first year
yeah about uh nine months okay and uh
it's been the best nine months ever oh
damn you're so stupid nice you're gonna
be great Levi's with us in Tulsa
Oklahoma hi Levi what's up
hey how you doing appreciate your time
sure how can we help
yeah my biggest question is is basically
how long is too long for staying house
poor
okay give us some more some more details
Levi
ation I make about 60 000 a year as a
mail carrier and my wife just recently
we had a baby about 10 months ago
congratulations and
um we have been able to put him in a
child care with my family so we haven't
had to spend any money on that for now
but we my wife has decided she wants to
stay home and spend more time with the
baby and so that's
cut her sixty thousand dollar salary
completely out of our equation and we
have a twelve thirteen hundred dollar a
month payment for our house so with just
my salary that pushes us out of the
comfortable range yeah
well you know and what I don't want to
do is sign up for indefinite
so indefinite sounds like she's going to
stay at home and you're going to be a
mail carrier making 60k you're stuck
this is not sustainable because you
don't have an exit plan from house poor
if you've got a plan you got a plan and
you hold your breath meaning you're
going to do something to double your
income in the next two years or three
years then we hold our breath and get
through that right
right but 10 years from now you don't
want to be signed up for this exact same
trip
no no
the biggest problem is is I really like
my job it's going to increase but you
know federal government it's not going
to increase on what I need not much soon
no I mean your income went from 100 20
to 60. yeah your income went from 120 to
60. we have to have a path to get it
back to 100 or we've got to have a
different house
yeah and you know even in Tulsa Oklahoma
houses are we would be either renting in
a dumpy part of town or buying in a
dangerous part of town and
not really wanting to do either one of
those you know
it's uh I hate to be the kind of guy
that's like hey we really need you to go
work somewhere
um you know I don't want to look it's a
choice if she wants to be home it's not
going to be in that house or you're
going to change careers
okay
the math just isn't there yeah okay no I
don't care I don't care personally which
one you do
um but one of you is going to make some
different choices about your career you
or her or we're not going to live in
this house
that that's the thing and so the it's
not how you know and then if you tell me
hey I'm gonna do this thing I'm going to
ramp up and go I'm going to go to code
school and I'm gonna go make 150 000 a
year doing uh Ruby on Rails coding uh
okay and that's going to take me two
years okay we can hold our breath three
years I can do that all right and this
is a values conversation for you guys
for you and your wife to talk through
because in order for her to stay home
which is great be very delicate P.S when
you're talking to her she has a baby
less than a year and she wants to be
with the baby okay so be very delicate
when you're communicating with her but
to be but like like if that is worth it
to y'all then living in a small smaller
house is worth it it's a value system of
your family but it's gonna have to
sacrifice and you guys can do that it
might be further out of town yeah the
way that works that's right that's right
something like that
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
foreign